hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk i'm
actually here in
india um and um
really excited about my trip doing some
interesting stuff and
um just woke up and um was looking at my
email it's amazing to me how many people
ask me what makes a wine library tv
successful or why um
has it done well what is like the secret
what is the move
what do i need to do and let me talk to
you about one thing
i'm gonna promise you one thing it's not
the glitz and the glamour
it's not the camera that i use guys it's
not it's not the
blogging you know software and it's not
the widgets
it's not it's not the widgets it's not
the seo
guys it's about the two c's content
and community it's as simple as that
pump out great
[ __ ] as hard as you can every day
five days a week heck push at seven i
mean i push it hard at five but
seven is great too and community every
person that emails you
every person that is commenting about
you you need to search out what people
are saying you need to be part of the
conversation
and you need to give to them as much as
possible give them what they want
not what you want to give makes sense
you know
everybody's talking about how should i
edit what software do you use what
camera do you use
i mean all that glitz and glamour stuff
it's not working there's so many crap
podcasts out there
with billion dollar cameras and editing
tools for days
it's about giving from your heart with
content that you really understand
and more importantly giving back to the
community that supports your show
never ever ever take any viewer for
granted
content and community and you can have a
successful show too
on the internets